Baseball can be of a great benefit to the players.
Baseball teaches team-building skills.
All players must work together to accomplish the goal of scoring...
...and keeping the other team from scoring.
It teaches good sportsmanship.
Players must be courteous to each other.
Baseball is also great for developing hand-eye coordination.
Swinging the bat and making contact with the ball...
...is a lot more difficult than it sounds.
It takes timing and precision,...
...two skills that become better with hand-eye coordination.
Baseball also promotes exercise.
And overall, baseball is just fun.
Who knows, with a little practice,..
...anyone can be in the major leagues one day...
...with a multimillion dollar contract.